hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen today's video is
sponsored by
hellofresh and we'll be looking at san
vlut's updated
what i eat in a day now a lot of people
ask me about my thoughts on meal kits
and i've always said that i think
they're a great way to get a home-cooked
family meal on the table more nights of
the week
one that i've tried and enjoyed a lot in
the past and have been leaning
heavily on as a busy mom is hellofresh
the recipes are really delicious and
super easy prepare
with a lot of 20-minute options
vegetarian options
and unique recipes that i really
wouldn't think to make at home
all with step-by-step instructions i
also like that the meal plans are
flexible so that you can choose your
delivery days
and skip a week anytime without a big
commitment
and in terms of packaging and waste a
lot of families actually find that they
cut back on food waste
since they're using only the ingredients
that they need and
hello fresh's packaging is almost
entirely made from recyclable
or already recycled content i know so
many of us
are busy but still want to include more
fresh
home-cooked meals in our week so i love
that meal kits like
fresh make those family meal times more
realistic
and less stressful for busy families
check out the link below for an
exclusive offer when using my promo code
abby's kitchen okay so you may remember
that i actually already did a full
wedding day review
on sun a few months ago which you can
watch right here
but sun has since uploaded a few videos
on her new elimination diet that a lot
of you specifically
dm'd me about so today we're going to be
taking a look at this
new way of eating some of the health
implications of it
and my honest evidence-based thoughts
but of course before we start a few
very quick disclaimers the information
in this video is for educational and
entertainment purposes
only so you should always speak to a
healthcare professional about your
unique healthcare needs two the
recommendations for each individual meal
i review
is designed to give you a variety of
ideas on how to optimize meals
for balance variety and satiety whether
or not one individual meal or even one
day is balanced or
healthy does not matter in the grand
scheme of one's health
especially if a person is eating in
response to their physical
and emotional needs i really am giving
suggestions as examples and inspiration
for you
but of course you can also gather this
data for yourself
over time by just listening to your own
body
number three please be kind in the
comments both here and on san's channel
number four a trigger warning that some
graphics and discussions
may be disturbing to some of my viewers
so of course feel free to skip this
video
and five don't forget to subscribe to
this channel and ring that little bell
so that you never
miss out okay so for those of you who
have not watched my previous
what i in a day review on sun or maybe
have watched it but need a little bit of
a refresher
here are some of my main takeaways on
san's
previous diet number one she didn't cut
out any specific food groups so san
included
a variety of plant-based foods in her
meals
and did not seem to follow any specific
diet
or super strict eating regime she
generally seemed like a pretty flexible
eater while leaning more towards a
plant-based eating style
number two she emphasized nutrition
over calories so sam seemed less
preoccupied with tracking calories
and instead focused more on ensuring
that she nourished
and fueled her body with adequate
nutrition number three
her meal seemed generally balanced and
nutrient dense
sans meals while maybe not very
realistic for a lot of people
were generally pretty balanced delicious
and flavorful looking while providing an
adequate amount of calories
and number four she sometimes would
align herself with diet culture
messaging despite portraying a generally
balanced and flexible eating style
we did see sand subscribe to detox
culture
quite a bit there was a lot of diet
rhetoric in the detox day
as well as some misinformation about
nutrition
so here's hoping that we don't see more
of that
in the new videos here now in this video
i was happy to hear her give a
disclaimer that she wasn't a doctor
and that if you wanted to try this to of
course take it up with your healthcare
provider
but let's get into her trainer's body
reset
recommendation greetings from trying to
go into
labor at home folks um it seems like
youtubers are now kind of like in this
habit of
pulling videos after i've shot a
one-in-a-day video or review of them
but before i've had a chance to actually
pull the clips to edit them
so since i shot this video and i did it
a little bit a while ago because i'm
trying to
get ahead because baby is literally
coming right now
um i she has sam has told her
why we changed our diet video from june
and as annoying as it is for me of
course right now because i'm literally
in early labor and i'd like to focus on
that and not deal with this
um i am happy to see that son maybe
pull the video because it doesn't align
with her or her channel anymore
in fact when i went to her channel today
to see
how things have changed um she had just
released a new what i in a day kind of
summer eating style
and it seems to be more kind of like a
line with like paleo style of eating
which is still restrictive in my opinion
but not necessarily as
low-carb keto as she was doing with this
whole keto reset
program so some of the things that she
was eating for example
included a kale salad with quinoa
rice poached egg avocado a smoothie with
avocado
cocoa powder kale coconut oil almond
butter almond milk and dark chocolate
tacos with coconut flour and almond
flour tortillas
some cabbage slaw halibut and guacamole
and
some dark chocolate with tea for dessert
she's also still intermittent fasting
um however she does say that this is
kind of just like she does naturally
so it doesn't really feel like i guess
restrictive to her
um so if it works for her and it feels
good to her great it works for me having
said all of that
i'm still getting questions from a lot
of you in dms and messages
about whether or not this whole keto
reset concept
is healthy so it seems like this
video or these two videos have really
had a lasting effect on a lot of you
even after she's pulled them down so
because of that i do think it is
necessary for me to speak to
the concept of this keto diet reset and
whether or not
it is healthy um kind of helpful
and also even safe also a quick reminder
that i do really respect san for pulling
these videos
so big props to her for that so this
video that i shot a few months ago was
never really meant to be
a strict what i in a day review so i
really just wanted to speak to the
concept of the keto diet reset
as well as its intentions and its
impacts
so let's do it started doing like
a diet for one or two weeks where we're
researching which carbs will be good for
us
and we're determining element we're
doing kind of like an elimination diet
sorry i had to look at the word um where
we see where we have like certain
allergies or food sensitivities
so we started working out with this new
trainer and they were really
trying to find out also what caused
inflammation in his body
then for me i go i used to go to bed
at least a couple times a week with a
really
really painful stomach completely
bloated extremely
extremely gassy i have such
well-balanced meals right with my
protein carbs i've been always very on
top of that but i was
i felt that there was something in my
body what i was eating
what really really hurt and i was just
extremely gassy which is so
so uncomfortable i wanted to try this
out and see which foods actually
like work for us and which one those
okay so
according to her june 16th video why we
changed our diet
san and her partner are going on a
two-week body
reset with the intention of alleviating
things like
body pain muscle soreness inflammation
gas and bloating so this body reset
comes at the recommendation of their
trainer
who claims that going on a keto diet for
two weeks
and completely eliminating carbohydrates
is a guaranteed way to
fix these problems so this means for
them
only eating fats and proteins and some
vegetables
while cutting out carbs dairy eggs
sugar and nightshade veggies on top of
all of these restrictions san also
mentions that she is
intermittent fasting so yeah
that's a lot of rules but at the end of
these two weeks
they apparently will slowly reintroduce
carbohydrate-containing foods
and test their blood sugar levels to
assess their body's reaction to that
food
and whether or not it affects their
system in a good way or a
bad way there's a lot to unpack here
to start off apparently they're testing
their blood sugar to see if this
reset resolves their inflammation now
while blood tests
are often used to detect inflammation in
the body
these blood tests will specifically look
at
inflammatory markers like c-reactive
protein
plasma viscosity and erythrocyte
sedimentation rate
testing blood sugar levels would not be
considered an indicator of
inflammation blood sugar levels are
instead
an indicator of how efficient your body
is
at breaking down and absorbing
carbohydrates for fuel
so if the purpose of this reset is to
relieve inflammation
it doesn't really make any sense to me
that they're using their blood sugar
levels
as a gauge of success number two one of
the other reasons that sun is going on
an elimination diet
is to improve her digestive issues like
bloating
and gas now while elimination diets are
often recommended to help identify food
triggers for digestive issues
keto is not typically how it's done
research has found that the keto diet or
a very low carb diet
may be associated with relief from ibs
or other digestive disorders
but it's believed that this is not
because of ketosis per se
but because of a reduction in
fermentable carbohydrates
otherwise known as high fodmap foods
that just
tend to accompany a low carb regime
i also want to note that depending on
the true cause of the digestive issue
the keto diet may actually make things
worse
one of the major complaints about keto
is the risk of constipation due to a
lack of fiber
and there is some early research to
suggest that it may even cause
inflammation
and reduce the concentration of good
bacteria in the gut
so obviously we need more research in
this area
but until then keto would not be the
first step i would suggest
most digestion rds would plan a proper
low fodmap elimination diet
which would involve removing foods that
are high in fodmaps and then gradually
reintroducing them back in varying
amounts it's not meant to be a
reset and it's not meant to be a
lifelong diet either
it's a carefully controlled test that
should be overseen
by a dietitian not a trainer for whom
therapeutic diets
like this is really out of their scope
as for keto and inflammation
there was some research suggesting that
a very low carb diet
may help reduce inflammation in those
with type 2 diabetes
however they also found that there were
just naturally
higher rates of inflammation in people
with insulin resistance so it's unclear
how this can be applied to the general
population not to mention that the
impact was dependent on the
type of carbohydrate with refined or
simple carbs
having the biggest inflammatory effect
now nightshade veggies like tomatoes
eggplants potatoes and peppers
are often thought to be pro-inflammatory
specifically in the context of arthritis
and this is due to their alkaloid
content
specifically the alkaloid solanine there
is also some animal and test tube
research suggesting that nightshade
veggies
may increase inflammation but according
to the arthritis foundation
this is largely a myth in fact
a 2011 study found that both
inflammation
and arthritis was actually reduced in
healthy men who ate nightshades for six
weeks
and then another 2013 study found that a
specific alkaloid
found in nightshades called anitabine
had
powerful anti-inflammatory effects of
course research is not anecdotal
experience so
some people may find relief from cutting
out a variety of things
i'm not discounting anyone's experience
here
but this is why it's important to really
work with a dietitian
to properly identify unique triggers
specific to you and finally
sam mentions that by following this diet
she'll be eating
a lot of meat which is definitely
something that it doesn't seem like
she's
used to and as we've seen in her
previous videos
she tends to have a preference towards
eating more plant-based foods so
this will definitely be a change of pace
but if the purpose of this diet is to
reduce
inflammation eating larger quantities of
meat on a more frequent basis
probably wouldn't be my first
recommendation
as research shows that higher red meat
intakes
are associated with increased risk of
inflammation
now with all of that said i feel like
the focus of this diet
is just to remove foods that may be
allegedly inflammatory
which doesn't leave us with a whole lot
i believe it may be just as important if
not more important
to add foods in that are
anti-inflammatory
so this includes foods with omega-3 fats
like fatty fish
olive oil walnuts and flax seed all of
which
are keto friendly options foods that are
high in antioxidants are
also anti-inflammatory and they often
include foods that are
not so much keto friendly like fruit and
some starchy vegetables
honestly i'm just getting the impression
that the term body reset
is like a synonym for detox as
sun is using a lot of the same rhetoric
we heard her use in her detox video
so unfortunately we're already off to a
not so great start
and one that doesn't make a whole lot of
sense to begin with
based on basic human physiology
but let's take a look at some of sans
meals and warning again
i'm gonna talk numbers so since i can't
necessarily show her meals
i am cutting out any of my in-depth
commentary on these meals just to be
fair
and like i said this video was never
really meant to be a strict wedding day
review anyways it's more about
the concept of the keto diet reset
however
just to give you guys some context and
an understanding of
some of her recommendations that her
trainer was giving her
i want to share my rough thoughts and my
rough notes on
what she was eating that day so sam's
menu included
some bulletproof coffee a salad with
lots of veggies greens avocado olives
and oil
fried brussels sprouts in oil with
avocado and a chocolate pudding made of
avocado
cocoa powder almond butter oil and
protein powder
so overall when we look at sam's meals
for the day
she's getting around 95 grams of
carbohydrates
which makes up around 23 of her calories
from carbs as i mentioned the keto diet
recommendation for carbs
is usually less than around 50 grams in
order to stand ketosis
which would be between five to ten
percent
of total calories from carbs for the day
i have to be honest
i'm just not really sure what the goal
is here
is it ketosis reducing bloating and
inflammation
just eating a healthy low carb and
higher fat plant-based diet
it seems like none of these goals are
being met adequately
because sans trainer has her tackling
way too much at one time
and none of it seems actually evidence
based
or aligned with sun's personal
preferences but anyways
let's move on to part two now in her
follow-up video entitled a model trice
elimination diet and results
son talks about the hate that she got
from her first video
and that she was simply sharing her
journey and not suggesting that anyone
else follow suit
now i really always appreciate
influencers putting out disclaimers like
this
because some people will hopefully take
it with a grain of salt
but there will always be a huge
proportion of her followers
who will watch this and think well if a
model is doing this extreme diet
and i am bloating too i should do it too
as
influencers we have a huge amount of
responsibility for
what we put out there and there was a
lot of
misinformation that clearly wasn't fact
checked before it went out case in point
this right here
this week we will be doing a carb test
thing
which means we're gonna take our blood
sugar levels before and after we
eat carbs and we're gonna see what it
does with a spike in her body
so if it spikes a lot i mean i'm i'm
using really basic terms right now not a
nutritionist at all if it spikes a lot
your body changes a carbohydrate
immediately into like insulin and
fat and if it doesn't spike that much
your body use really the carbohydrate
for energy
well first of all again i don't know
what blood sugar testing has to do with
inflammation and bloating
we have a lot of groundwork to cover
here now we typically see people with
diabetes checking their blood sugars
before and after a meal
to evaluate the effect of that meal on
their corresponding blood sugar levels
or to determine how much insulin they
may need
but again it doesn't really have
anything to do with inflammation
and if you don't have diabetes testing
your blood sugar levels before and after
you eat
is unnecessary because your insulin
functions
optimally enough to bring blood sugar
levels back down
into the normal range it doesn't matter
if you're eating
low carb or high carb if you are healthy
your blood sugars will stay within a
normal range i'm also a bit concerned
about sans
understanding of carbohydrates blood
sugar levels
insulin and how they all relate to one
another
so to clarify for all of you when we
consume a carbohydrate containing food
the body breaks it down into glucose
which is used for energy
the body does not break down
carbohydrates into insulin
as sand describes insulin is actually
the hormone that's released from the
body and helps the body get glucose
into the cells so that it can be used
for energy insulin is released
from the body every time we eat
carbohydrates
regardless of the effect that it has on
blood sugar levels
the only time that carbohydrates get
converted into fat
is if more glucose is consumed than what
can be comfortably stored as glycogen
which is the storage form of glucose so
with all this in mind
i can understand why sun would think
that a high blood sugar spike
might mean that the carbohydrate would
be used as fat
but that's not necessarily the case
eating one high glycemic index food
like white rice for example does not
mean that it will be immediately
converted into fat
it really has more to do with an overall
pattern of eating
and not about one type of food eaten at
one
point in time also in general we don't
usually eat carbohydrate foods
in isolation we often combine foods like
white rice
with a source of protein fat and some
fibrous veggies
all of which can help to slow down the
rate at which glucose is broken down
in the body and used for energy bottom
line
sans trainer is peddling some serious
faulty
science let's hear a little bit more now
for one week
i have zero complaints with my stomach i
wake up
like it's super flat it's not even about
that it just feels very good i feel
lighter
i think in that way it's been a really
good week
on the other side though i love food so
much and i really miss
like eggs and like nuts and all these
things because you would be surprised
like how many things you cannot eat with
this
so for me every time frying veggies with
like a protein it's just it gets boring
especially around like lunch time
because we're also intermitting fasting
i just want to have like breakfast i
want oats or i want like a smoothie or
something and we can't really have that
right now i
do feel really good which is a good
thing i find
food very boring right now okay so sam
says that she's feeling pretty good on
this diet which is great to hear
though i don't love that she describes
her digestive relief in terms of being
super flat
and lighter but whatever minor point
the bigger issue is that this relief
comes at the cost of her saying that
she's
bored with foods that she's allowed to
eat and misses
a lot of her go-to's like eggs smoothies
oatmeal and nuts if you were to ask me
i would say that this bogus combination
of restrictions
and faux keto is not the reason
for her relief but rather that she's
reduced a lot
of high fodmap carbs so since she went
to the extreme of cutting out carbs
even low fodmap carbs it does make sense
that she's
feeling pretty good and it's unfortunate
that she did this whole
non-evidence-based roundabout way of a
low
fodmap trial because a it wasn't even
done properly as i did pick up on a few
higher fodmap foods in her day like
mushrooms and brussels sprouts
and b there were so many
foods that were cut out unnecessarily at
this point
this diet trial or reset has told sun
nothing specific about the actual unique
foods
causing her grief and in order to do
this properly
she's going to have to start again under
the supervision of a dietitian
who can walk her through the careful
steps
of a properly planned elimination diet
the goal
is not to remove fodmaps or groups of
foods for life
the goal is to test each subclass and
also at different amounts to come to
conclusions on
which are actually issues for her
let's see what her carb testing revealed
yesterday
i did rise and went up from 74 to 160
guys
and i love white rice
so obviously you're gonna ask me does
this mean i'm never gonna eat rice again
no absolutely not i love it
um i love sushi too but it's just for me
good to know that
whenever i really want to build up the
muscle and like get dry
that i should probably not eat rice but
try something else
so yeah okay so san tested white rice
and found that her blood sugar went up
from 74 to 160.
um i'm not really surprised
white rice is classified as a high
glycemic index food meaning
it increases blood sugar faster than
foods with more fiber
that provide a more steady stream of
energy
it's important to know however that
eating rice in combination with
other foods would not have had the same
impact on blood sugar levels
which is actually really important thing
to keep in mind this is why i always
talk so much about aiming for
higher fiber carbohydrates and pairing
them with a source of protein
or fat aka not eating naked carbs
whenever you can and most of us do this
naturally because we have sushi
or stir-fry or rice and beans etc
most of us don't have mono meals of just
one
single ingredient i'm also glad to hear
that san
doesn't intend to stop eating rice
because of some of these
results because rice is something that
she actually just really really loves
however she also said that this
information is good to know
because now she knows not to eat rice
whenever she wants to
build muscle and get dry so
not only is there some obvious confusion
and misinformation
around the relationship between
carbohydrates and insulin and blood
sugar levels
but also around muscle building and
carbs as well
getting dry and building muscles are two
very different goals each with two very
different sports nutrition protocols
to build muscles obviously you need some
kind of
loaded stimulus like lifting weights
plus
you'll need enough protein to rebuild
and maintain those muscles
carbohydrates even high glycemic index
carbs
are actually helpful in this situation
because a
they help give you the energy to perform
this work and
b they elicit an insulin response to
help drive the protein
into the muscle faster now getting dry
is actually not a healthy state period
this is something that people do just to
get stage ready for like a fitness
competition
and is unfortunately a look that people
strive for because they stare at
instagram models all day
but getting dry for a fitness
competition may involve
limiting water and limiting carbs to dry
out your glycogen stores
and then right before your show you
might be instructed to
carb load to fill your glycogen stores
just enough that your muscles look
pronounced and full but not too much
that they spill over into the space
between
your muscle and your skin and then you
look what they call
watery so i just want to clear up that
these are two
very different goals with two very
different ways of achieving them
with the latter being a potentially
dangerous one
for the general population again all of
this test really tells us
is that eating rice in isolation of
other foods
will spike your blood sugar levels which
is something
we already know for everyone
that is normal and healthy and unless
you have diabetes
is not actually a major issue other than
the fact that
maybe it leaves you hungry soon after
because it lacks
staying power let's see some of her
conclusions from the experiment really
a lot for me also like white rice but
does that mean that i
never can eat that no it doesn't it just
means
that when i want to eat carbs for energy
instead of fat
i should eat um chickpeas brown rice and
like sourdough bread
and we're going to obviously talk to a
doctor about all of this but
it actually does make sense and just as
a cool experiment it was fun to do
okay so this is a good little takeaway
from this experiment
of course carbs that are lower in fiber
fat or protein
are going to have a greater impact on
blood sugar levels
than those that are packaged up with
some of these state-shading compounds
like chickpeas or higher fiber bread
brown rice
etc i mean she could have also skipped
the whole keto diet thing
and just looked up the glycemic index
chart online
but i also totally get that some people
really like that personalized experience
and data collection and that's great
again the glycemic index of individual
carb foods isn't really that important
because we tend to eat them with sources
of protein
or sources of fat which will completely
alter
the overall glycemic load but bottom
line
i fully get that a lot of people want to
get to the bottom of their unpleasant
symptoms
like bloating gas and inflammation which
is a
kind of vague ambiguous term to begin
with to be honest
and yes a proper elimination diet would
be the best way to achieve this
that pursuit is not my issue here my
issue
is that the diet and the methodology of
testing its effectiveness
did not complement the goals here at all
and was really not evidence-based which
is something that an
actual dietitian would be really careful
to consider
so a testing blood sugars to come to the
conclusion that brown rice
has a less aggressive effect on blood
sugars compared to white rice
does not tell us anything about bloating
or gas
or inflammation and actually sam didn't
even comment on the impact
of this test on inflammation whatever
that means to her
b going pseudo keto plus removing
nightshades
may be like a roundabout way to reduce
bloating depending on the cause
but it certainly added a lot of
restrictions and is
not as complete as a low fodmap trial
and c testing blood sugars if you don't
have diabetes
or insulin resistance doesn't tell us
anything about how well
a reset worked because blood sugars will
always be regulated within a healthy
range period
this diet sounds like a legitimate hell
and just not compatible with sans diet
or lifestyle especially in combination
with intermittent fasting that she
already does it's also unnecessarily
restrictive
and will probably need to be redone in
order for son to get
any actual answers on her symptoms this
my friends is why you want to work with
a qualified
nutrition professional for making any
changes to your diet
because at best it can be a few brutal
weeks of unnecessary discomfort that
does not bring you
any kind of long-term relief and at
worst
it can be actually dangerous for your
physical and mental health
ultimately i really hope that san is
able to move on from this
reset experiment and find a way of
eating that is sustainable for her
and also helps give her the relief that
she seeks well folks that is all for
today's video
and again a big thank you again to
hellofresh for sponsoring
if you like this video please be sure to
give it the thumbs up
leave me a comment below with who you'd
like to see me review next until then
subscribe to the channel
and i'll see you next time on abby's
kitchen bye
you